jean marais il ya très longtemps que
vous voit au cinéma et on vous voit de
plus en plus dans des films d' aventure
oui parce que les metteurs en scène me
demande dans des films d'aventurés
si j'avais choisi entre dix films dont
neuf d'aventuré un film de criminologie
ou réalise je dirais peut-être le film
réaliste j'ai envie on a toujours envie
de changer de style bull pendant
l'ouverture de la bourse
il faut que la porte s'ouvre dans le
recul qui comme suffisantes
on attendait se retourne même plutôt sur
cinq parties peut-être là gayet auquel
bafouille troisième enquête commissaire
oui ça se passe vous êtes tous là
actuellement sur nous en écosse ces
photos masque imam un impôt sur le droit
de vivre certaines personnes très très
riche
ils l'ont même si ta peau tenant peau de
quelques milliards s'il ne paye pas ou
peu - et 10 % s'ils payent pas sont
abattues le riz alors le log macra
schleck et jean roger caussimon me fait
venir parce que je suis un spécialiste
de fantômas le commissaire jules le
souvenir de paris pour enquêter pour
frontonas
oui ça y est je me revoilà avec son
taser à nouveau et comment ça se passe
très bien
l'ambiance a très bien l'ambiance est
toujours la même
or voilà l'ambiance est toujours la même
avec jean marais avec mylène avec
coaching dinars
nous devons tout faire grand cas pour
tout le monde ici oui monsieur et mylène
et en face s'arrêtant par exemple juste
au logement
ça va